T
COMES.
WE CAN BUILD ROADS AND BRIDGES
IF THEY SEE THESE BURDEN SUMMER
THERE'S OF BOOKS ON THE LAW
CALLED THE NATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY ACT OF 1969
AND REMEMBER, A LOT OF THAT
DIDN'T HAPPEN AND A LOT OF MONEY
GOT WASTED BECAUSE OF THAT SO I
DON'T THINK THEY'RE THINKING
ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATIONS OF
THIS AND THE CONSEQUENCES OF A
LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE EITHER.
>> Jesse: IS BIDEN NOT THE
DEALMAKER WE THOUGHT HE WAS?
>> Jessica: I DON'T THINK
JOE BIDEN HAS FAILED AT ALL THUS
FAR, $1.9 TRILLION AMERICAN
PACKAGE IS A CORE COMPONENT OF
THE AMERICAN JOBS ACT AND
MITCH McCONNELL SET OVER THE
WEEKEND IF THE RECONCILIATION
ISN'T NECESSARILY TIED TO THIS,
REPUBLICANS SHOULD BE FOR THIS.
EVERYONE WANTS INFRASTRUCTURE
AND REPUBLICANS IN STATES WITH
CRUMBLING BUILDINGS IN FLORIDA
NOW.
THERE ARE DISASTERS ALL AROUND.
I'M NOT SAYING IT'S GOING TO
FUND SURFSIDE BUT PEOPLE ARE
SURROUNDED BY THINGS THAT ARE
BROKEN AND REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS WANT TO FIX THEM.
>> Jesse: YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE
IS CRUMBLING?
YOUR IVORY TOWER CRASHING DOWN.
>> Jessica: JOE BIDEN HAS
GOTTEN WHAT HE WANTED AND I
THINK WE ALL REMEMBERED THE
SQUAD WAS LIKE I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE GOING TO VOTE FOR
NANCY PELOSI AS SPEAKER AND THEN
THEY ALL LINED UP AND VOTED FOR
NANCY PELOSI.
THEY FELL IN LINE AND
BERNIE SANDERS HAS ALSO FALLEN
IN LINE THROUGHOUT HIS 50 YEAR
CURMUDGEONLY CAREER SO I THINK
JOE BIDEN WILL BE ABLE TO GET
THIS DONE WITH THE SPENDING
BILL.
>> Katie: BUT CAN THEY TRUST
DEMOCRATS DO NOT THEN SPEND.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT I ALWAYS
SAY, WHEN YOU SAW THE VIDEO OF
AOC SCREAMING AT BIDEN FROM
OUTSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE, WHAT
DID YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> Greg: I THOUGHT
INSURRECTION, INSURRECTION.
WITH THE USE OF INFRASTRUCTURE
IF YOU GET USE IT WITH THESE GAS
PRICES?
YOU SEE HOW HIGH THE GAS PRICES
ARE, THEY ARE INSANE.
BY THE WAY, I DON'T KNOW IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN WITH THIS THING
BUT WHISPERING JOE DID JUST BOMB
A BUNCH OF PLACES.
THE MEDIA DIDN'T REALLY SEEM TO
MIND BECAUSE FOREIGN DEATH IS
PREFERABLE TO MEAN TWEETS ABOUT
CNN.
THAT THE ETERNAL IRONY IS YOU
DON'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT
ABRASIVE PERSONALITY ANYMORE AND
JOE IS SO KIND, BOMB AWAY.
>> Jesse: MAYBE HE WAS BOMBING
TO DISTRACT FROM HIS FAILED
INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL.
NOW I'M A C